bruce springsteen this is true Bruce  Springsteen is such a fan of the Harry  Potter movies he wrote a song for one of  the films sent it to the producers and  they rejected it yes he admitted this he  said I wrote a song for Harry Potter and  it was rejected everyone's wondering  what was that song like yeah we managed  to get a copy you don't lie about stuff  like this have a listen  this is a broken town the sorting hat  chooses only pain  [Music]  [Music]  - American  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  let's freeze our lawns to all the  Wizards Steelworkers  the American farmers is trying to string  together have Monday Phoebus failed  Wingardium Leviosa  [Applause]  I think he had something there  you